a rare Glimpse inside a private meeting
in Washington between the UK team and
the head of the international monetary
fund we know that
let me uh
there is clearly tension here the IMF
thinks Britain will be the weakest
economy on the G7 this year the
chancellor begs to differ we're very
focused on proven you wrong excellent
can you explain what does that mean what
are we talking about here well the IMF
head said to me that she very much hopes
I do prove her wrong um I think the
context here Ed is that last year we had
the fastest growing G7 economy so we did
very well last year we have so far
avoided recession this year so the
economy has shown resilience but we want
to be growing faster but do you think
that those IMF forecasts are wrong is
that your is that your hunt well
um the office for Budget responsibility
which is the government's official
forecaster has much more optimistic
forecast so if you're asking me which I
think is more likely to be the case I
would go with the obr but the latest
vote from nurses on further strikes
won't help what we say is that we will
talk about anything except a deal that
would mean that inflation is entrenched
and we're having the same discussion
this time next year because that's the
root cause of people's anger it's seeing
inflation above 10 the cost of the
weekly shop going up is there a concern
here about what this means for
the Health Service itself I urge people
are still voting for this pay deal to
recognize the fact that union leaders
say it's fair and reasonable patients
want the NHS to be back to normal and it
will be better for staff as well
Britain's not alone and facing these
problems it's just that it seems that
bit worse in the UK right now on growth
on strikes on the cost of living in his
effort to prove the fund wrong the
chancellor may have his work cut out Ed
Conway Sky News in Washington